[DING]
So reactlog is a memory
leak by definition.
So we have to opt into it.
And we can opt into it using
reactlog, reactlog enable.
So I'll go ahead
and enable that now.
And then we can go ahead and
run our Shiny application
no problem, just like
we're used to doing.
And this one is the
old faithful example
that we're used to seeing
of all of the waiting times.
And so we can change the bin
count and the plot updates.
Great.
We can then view the reactlog
by doing Command, fn, 3, for me.
And it might be like option
or control, fn, 3 for Windows,
I can't quite remember.
But your reactlog will show
up in a separate window.
And there's lots going on
here, but for just quick look
we can see our input bins
that we had on the left.
And on the right, we
can see our output
of our distribution plot, a
dist plot from the application.
And let's take a look.
So the way that reactlog works
is it flows from left to right.
And I made the pieces so that
they fit in like a puzzle.
So you can have your
inputs here on the left,
and they can join into your
reactive values in the middle.
So it joins in there and
needs to be finished off
with an output value
on the far right.
In this case, there is
a theme counter here,
but that's not having
any outputs listen to it.
So that's why it's all
the way on the right.
So we kind of align right
on all of the values.
But theme counter we can ignore.
We're mainly just interested
in the output of the distPlot.
The reactlog, if we
look, let's just kind of
walk through the top
of this status bar.
So we have the eight
navigation buttons at the top.
The first and last
are traversing
between marked steps.
We haven't done that yet, and
we'll come back to that later.
The next ones is
a tall green bar.
That's this tall
green bar here, which
is when Shiny was idle for
at least a millisecond.
It declared that it was idle.
And then the short
green bar is an output.
So an output calculation.
And you can jump between
prior and previous outputs.
So you may calculate
five outputs
and then Shiny becomes idle.
So you may want
to jump in between
to see how your active updates.
But the ones that I use a lot
are these middle two, which
is previous step and next step.
And I don't like to use
the mouse that often,
so we can actually use the
right arrow and left arrow.
And you can hold it and
you can hold it back.
And the KeyCastr is showing
that I was holding that there.
So that's pretty exciting.
Reactlog defaults
to the first time
that Shiny was idle
because it doesn't actually
know where you want to start.
I find starting at the end was--
where I launched reactlog
was too far away.
Because most likely,
I want to build up
into the unexpected error.
Or build up into what I'm trying
to learn about the application.
So I started it at the
first stable location.
And stable is when most of
the outputs, or in this case,
all of the outputs and
reactive values are green.
They are in the ready state.
If they were not
in the ready state,
and they're actually
performing some calculations,
they will be yellow.
It's useful to see
these different states.
In the future I'd actually
like to show more states,
like a red for an error occurred
or something like a wreck
false.
But I was just trying
to show currently
what Shiny is aware of.
Because technically, a req()
false is a valid result.
And so it's not
calculating anything.
It is actually ready to move
on even though the value is not
what we want.
So it'd be better
in the future if we
could differentiate those.
So now we're at an
idle, and let's take
a peek at what happens when--
Remember, I changed
the bins in the plot.
So in the sidebar
I changed the--
This is where the
width actually changed.
Probably due to the
width of the plot
actually was changing probably
due to this little showcase
mode on the side.
And so two times the plot was
redrawn because the output
width changed.
So let's walk
actually through when
I change the int of the bins.
And so I changed
it from 30 to 21.
And the way Shiny works is
all downstream dependencies
will be invalidated.
And they will remove
all connections
both up and downstream
from their connections.
So it's not fully
invasive, but it
is invasive for everything
downstream of this input value.
So let's walk through it.
This will tell,
so the input bins
will say, hey all my
downstream listeners you now
should start invalidating.
So plot output, or a plotObj
will start invalidating.
He's going to tell of his
downstream dependencies which
is going to be the
output distPlot.
Output distPlot says OK I
will start invalidating.
They will start
invalidating, by removing,
all upstream dependencies.
So the black lines are now
becoming thin little lines.
The thin lines I kept in
there to say a connection
has occurred in this recording
but it is currently not there.
Where if it's a thicker
line, then that means
it's actively a dependency.
OK, distPlot has
removed all connections
and it is invalidated.
So now we are backing out
of our invalidating process
and plotObj will remove
its last dependency
and is now finally invalidated.
And then the input
value is done,
and it will just
automatically jump over
into the next step, which is
the output starts calculating.
Shiny works in a model
where it finds all the data
that it needs to render.
It is not necessarily
a push model.
So I did not push input
bins into the plot object.
It's actually the plot object
is reaching up and finding
input bins.
It's a little different than
the way we think about it.
It's because of the
two different steps
where the first part was input
bins tells all downstream
to invalidate.
But then it's a free for all.
Finally now output distPlot
can then work its way
upstream until it's satisfied.
So output distPlot
starts calculating
says, hey, I need
the plot object.
Plot object says, I
haven't calculated
so I need to start calculating.
Then it says, well, I don't
have everything I need.
I need a connection
to in this case,
it's these unexpected
three items here.
The client data output distPlot
width, client data output
distPlot height, and also
client data pixel ratio.
These three pieces
of information
are necessary to draw
an image in Shiny.
And I think it's really neat,
because if you squeeze the plot
we should redraw it because it
doesn't really look like it's
going to fill the proper area.
If you make the
plot taller we want
to redraw it so your output
height and width will change.
And then your pixel
ratio is, if you actually
do like command plus
or command minus
and you go to retina display
or non retina display,
the quality of the image
will need to be adjusted.
And so in this case,
plotObj is going
to be retrieving those
values via an isolate.
That's why it has a dashed line.
So it's isolating on the value.
And then it removes
the connection
because an isolation does
not have any reactivity.
And then we get the pixel
ratio value and the input bins.
At this point plotObj said,
hey, I got all my values,
I'm calculated.
So we can go back
to the distPlot
and continue the calculations.
In this case distPlot does
have a hard dependency
on the output distPlot
width, the height,
and the pixel ratio.
Mentally thinking, I
thought it would actually
be inside the
plotObj but it just
happens to be in
the output distPlot.
distPlot is now satisfied,
and it is done calculating.
All of the outputs have
now been calculated.
So therefore Shiny is idle.
Yes, it was.
It happened at 11.45,
and it finished at 11.51.
So 0.06 of a second.
So the timeline across the top
does not represent actual time.
It represents steps taken.
And so you can have
many steps taken
in a very short amount of time.
And you can have
hardly any steps
taken in a very long
amount of actual time.
Such as when I go
from this step--
And so as we were
talking about there,
the time up here
represents the time
since recording or
starting the application,
and then the session represents
what Shiny session it
belongs to.
Typically when you
open up a reactlog,
that session will be isolated
to any global sessions
such as Shiny idle, or any
session that I am running in.
So in this case, I'm running
in the Shiny session 2D7
blah, blah, blah.
And between these two steps
about ten seconds had elapsed.
So Shiny was idle at
the one second mark
and then we started changing
the value ten seconds later.
Just a quick to show about
switching between idles so
if we click the button here,
we can go back and forth
between idle sessions.
Most likely that's
something where
you know you've done something
within the application.
The graph doesn't necessarily
change because the app
is fairly small.
In the last one that I want to
show in this is the searching.
So you can search for
these labels here.
So in this case, I can search
for let's say plot and all
the things that show up.
Or even capital Plot.
These three items all
contain a capital P in plot
and this is a smaller app so
the searching isn't quite as
effective.
But if I did the lowercase
plot it's still the same graph
because the ancestors and
descendants are the same.
Another way to go
around this, I like
to hit Escape to escape that
searching that was done.
Another fun one is that you
can single click an item.
So it kind of shows up while
you move around and do things.
So you can see that
one specifically.
Escape to get rid of it.
But what I like to do
is to double click.
And it will kind
of make it bigger.
It'll highlight it,
and it will find
all of its ancestors and
descendants, its whole family
tree.
And when you move
back and forth,
it will only be for that
tree that is displayed.
So if there are
other reactives, you
have 1,000 other reactives above
or below that aren't shown,
we'll skip over all of them.
So we'll only look at the
reactivity for the sub
tree that is displayed.
And that is really
useful, because when
you have an app like Gradient.
I think on load it has about
2,500 reactive IDs created.
Yeah, it's big.
It's a very big app.
It's wonderful for testing
by the way, thank you.
And has a lot of
different corner cases.
But yeah it's a
very large graph.
Very shallow graph, actually.
I was very surprised about that.
Not very many dependencies,
something like this,
like three layers deep.
But useful nonetheless.
So let's look at a
more direct example.
Looking at Pythagoras
app, and I like
to look at this one as an app
that people aren't necessarily
familiar with.
Because we know the
Pythagoras Theorem,
we know how to calculate it.
But we can do this
through reactivity
because if I change A or B, then
my output C should also update.
That's how the definition
of the triangle is done.
And let's look at how we would
calculate Pythagoras theorem.
So to calculate that, we need
to first calculate A squared.
We can label it with A squared.
And I highly recommend
you giving anything
that you can a label
because most likely,
you'll have a
multi-line expression
and possibly your
first few lines might
be very similar to other
reactive expressions.
And so your default label is
not going to be that useful.
Instead we know
this is A squared.
So I can give it a nice
value of A squared.
This is underutilized but
is very effective when
viewing the reactlog.
So future you will thank you for
your work that you do up front.
So we have A squared, calculate.
We then have B squared
and we calculate it.
Great.
Given these two reactive
values we can retrieve them,
add them together
to make C squared.
And then finally,
given C squared
we can take the square root
of it and have our answer, C.
This value is then
displayed via render text
and also a render print just
so that we have more outputs
to look at.
But it could just be done with
a single render print or render
text.
OK so let's run
this application.
In the top I have a
reactlog react log enable
to enable the reactivity.
And then finally I will
call Command fn F 3 just
to open up the viewer.
So let's run the application.
Cool.
So this is a fun surprise I
skipped over it in the code.
You don't necessarily need
to always open up the viewer.
Instead what you can do is add
a UI value and a server value.
The UI value is
reactlog module UI.
So it's a UI module that you
can add into your application
just so the reactlog
is inserted in
and you don't need to
open up in multiple pages.
To pair with this, we need to
have the reactlog module server
so that we can update
those values in the UI.
It won't magically
just occur, Shiny
needs to be told that
these things can be done.
So that's where
that's coming from.
So in our application, we
have our A, we have our B,
and we have our C. Output
C and output C. Two
different outputs.
And the reactlog
looks like this.
So we have A to A
squared, B to B squared.
A squared and B squared
makes C squared.
C squared can be
square rooted into C.
And C is then stored in the
output, C verbatim and C text.
And that matched exactly how
we had in our application.
Input A to A
squared, input B to B
squared, A squared and B
squared pointing to C squared,
and the square root
of C squared makes
C. And that matches our labels,
everything is nice and tidy,
and we can see our
images right in the app.
Very exciting.
You'll notice that there's this
extra item of a theme counter.
That's for things like Bootstrap
Lib, where we update the theme
and do things like that.
You can feel free to ignore it.
It's not a big deal.
And then this extra line here
is the reactlog module UI
and the IFrame.
Because this is actually
an IFrame to the reactlog
information.
So we can just feel
free to ignore that.
That's not a big deal.
OK so let's look at what
happens when we change this
to 5 and 12.
We get the 5 12, 13 triangle.
Great.
Not too big of a surprise.
Let's refresh our reactlog
because more reactivity
has occurred.
And it only loads it
up to the first time
when we did the application
when it was idle.
So we can walk through this
application using our arrow
keys, and when we change
the value A went from 3 to 5
so all the downstreams
get invalidated.
And they're
invalidating by removing
all of their dependencies
and marking themselves
as invalidated.
And then they work
their way back up.
And B squared was not a
direct descendant of A.
So therefore, B squared
will keep its value
but it will just
remove the connection
from B squared to C squared.
C squared is actually initiating
that removal of the connection.
And so B squared it is
going to stay calculated.
And if you were
to ask its value,
it would return immediately.
It would not need to recalculate
because it was not invalidated.
And then once all of those
investigations occur,
Shiny sits there
and goes OK, what
outputs need to be calculated.
And we'll walk
through that again.
So C verbatim says,
hey, I need a value.
It captures C. C needs to
work its way up because it
doesn't have a value.
A squared works its way up,
gets A, calculates its value.
C squared is now
happy with A squared,
but it also needs the B squared.
B squared in this case has
already been calculated,
so it returns its
value immediately.
No time is spent
calculating B squared.
I'm up the tree back
down to C verbatim.
C verbatim is
happy, but we still
have more outputs to calculate.
So we'll move on to C text.
C text will then look at C and
say, hey, I need your value.
C will be like, great,
here's my value, we're done.
There's no more
calculations needed.
Shiny has this automatic
caching value already done.
And so if a reactive value
has not been invalidated,
it will return its
value immediately
and no time is spent
calculating that.
And I think that's just great.
Like it's a neat little
trick hidden underneath.
And if you're to add an output
dynamically, like right now,
and all it needed was the
C value and B squared,
it would be instantaneous.
You wouldn't have no extra
overhead, and that is great.
And then we're done.
Shiny is idle.
But we also then
updated the value to 12
and we ran through the
same process again.
But we went up the B branch
instead of the A branch.
Done.
Shiny is idle.
And then the next
steps actually are
me clicking the Refresh button
and then the IFrame updating.
When you click the
Refresh button though,
it will always go back to
that first idle location.
And the reactlog is append only.
I don't cut it.
I don't do anything special.
I just append on
because I don't want
to hide the truth from
what's there from you.
So what you can do is
actually mark a time point.
And I find this really
useful because most
likely in your
Shiny application,
you will have to do many
steps to possibly get
to your bad reactivity.
And then you'll say, hey,
I need it mark this time
point because I know
the next steps that I
do maybe a little wonky.
So to mark a time point,
you can do Command fn, F4.
Or a little bit more
reliable, given your browser,
you can do Command,
Shift, fn, and F3.
So very similar to Command, fn,
F3 but you add in the Shift.
And what this will do is
it'll mark a time point.
So when we refresh
our application
it won't load to
where it's first idle.
It'll load to the last
marked time point.
So you can have many
marked time points,
but it'll load the last one.
And this is really nice
because if we go back
to a 3, 4 triangle.
Right, so 3, 4, 5,
and then I refresh.
It was loaded up before
refresh and so we can go--
I'm sitting in a
5, 12, 13 triangle.
And if I were to
move forward, this
is now running through and
converting it back to the 3, 4.
So right where I last
marked my time point.
So for completeness, I'm going
to do another marked time
point.
And I'm going to
refresh the reactlog.
So you can see the marked
time point down here.
And I can actually jump between
them using the black bar.
Because that is a
marked time point.
Maybe we should remove
them, unless they're there.
But I thought it was to
help show that it's possible
that they could be there.
OK so let's look at a
situation where reactlog will
help us debug our reactivity.
We had our Pythagoras
application here.
And now let's look
at a broken one.
So the difference between
Pythagoras and Pythagoras
broken is not that much.
The app will run and no
errors will be produced.
This is actually terrifying.
Because this means
it's a logic error
and it is not actually
a Shiny error.
So let's go ahead and
run the application
with our reactlog enabled.
So we're running
your application.
Great.
So what is going on here?
Our C value is 4.2.
It is not a 3, 4, 5 triangle.
And C squared is listening
to B squared sometimes
because there's a
connection being made.
But it's not solid.
And what?
B squared is listening to A?
This is weird.
So let's change it
to a 5 and a 12.
Still 7.
OK.
So odd.
All right so let's look
had this application.
So did actually it change?
Yeah, if I change
B nothing happens.
So this isn't good either.
So walking through the reactlog,
let's see what happens here.
So this is when I was changing
it into that 3, 4, 5 triangle.
So A changed into--
Or a 5, 12, 13.
So A changed into 5, great.
A is telling B to invalidate.
That seems odd.
So there it is.
Input A is B squared.
We should switch that.
So that is now B.
So personally, that's
a better logic change.
Let's just rerun the
application here.
So we'll run app again.
OK things are looking better.
Let's switch this to a 5.
And then we switch this to a 12.
And B is still broken.
That's not good.
But we can see that B squared
is taking an input from B.
So that seems better.
So we're doing better there.
So let's walk through
that adjustment.
So given that adjustment,
A turned into 5,
A squared, C squared,
OK everything's good.
Seems right.
Output C verbatim
is recalculating
getting its A squared.
And C squared is isolating
on B squared, odd.
And moving on.
OK so that's how that connection
was made at some point.
But it's not
connected right now.
And I guess that's
why it makes sense
that when B changes its value
all the way up to anything,
like 20, C is not changing.
So isolate value here.
We remove that B squared.
Great.
So we'll save it.
Let's kill the application
because we made a known logic
change that's better.
And things I believe
will be good.
So 5 and 12.
5, 12, 13 triangle.
And if we refresh
our reactlog, we
can see that A
makes its updates.
And we can also see
that we change B
and it'll make its updates.
And C was actually
updated twice,
which is what we want for
all the changes of A and B
and Shiny's idle.
So that's how we can
use it to help debug.
And it's helped
debug logic changes.
And this works really well when
your application is very large.
Because this can work
with a couple of thousand
of these different
reactives, no problem.
Just to show a
bigger application,
I'd like to look at
the cranwhales demo app
that Joe showed at
one of his keynotes.
So again, we're going to make
sure that reactlog is enabled.
We're going to run the
GitHub one application.
And this application shows
the top end downloaders
of all of cran that's
hosted by RStudio.
And it's usually the
80-20 rule, where
like six people are responsible
for a lot more than 20%
or 80% of the traffic, you
know depending on the day.
So we're thinking about it here.
And downloading that data.
Great, all right, so
the data has shown up.
We have some numbers up at the
top of the bandwidth consumed,
the files downloaded,
the unique downloaders.
So out of the 120,000
unique downloaders,
the green bars are
represented by 6 people.
So these are the whales.
And so it's the cranwhales.
And that's almost 50%
by those six people.
The biggest whales are
given random names.
And so The Full Puppy,
he's the biggest whale.
And by hours, actually
very interesting,
there's different behaviors.
Full Puppy looks kind of
like internet traffic.
The Glamorous Parakeet,
pretty consistent.
And The Glamorous Fish,
very spiked behavior.
And Immense Zebra
looks very constant.
So it's very
interesting to see as
to how these different
behaviors come about.
And then we can look in the
detailed view of let's say
Full Puppy.
And it's doing
some calculations.
Either way.
Moving on now.
So let's look at reactlog
so the Command, fn, F3.
This is a lot bigger.
We have A. So this is the
first time that Shiny was idle.
And we are looking at the--
Remember on that home screen,
we had three numbers up
at the top and a plot.
So we have our outputs
that have calculated.
We have the total size, K.
We have the total count,
and we have the total
number of downloaders.
Great.
And then finally there's this
plot output called All Hour.
And I'm recognizing
this as a plot
because it's listening to
the client data pixel ratio,
the height, and the width.
And there's a plot
object as well.
So that's like the
shape of an output plot.
These all listen to a data
set called whales, which
listens to the top end, or the
top count, and also what date.
And I think that's really neat
that you can see your data.
Everything is kind of
pointing to these whales,
and then things come from there.
So we can actually look--
Yeah, so it's neat.
Then the next thing that I did
is I clicked on the second tab.
So the second tab will start.
And let's see here.
And this will calculate
output downloaders.
So output downloaders then
says, hey, I now exist.
So let's make a plot because
the output downloaders wanted
to look at the biggest whales.
It's just the single plot.
And it runs through,
gets the plot object,
plot object gets all
of its information
and it pulls out the whales.
Whales is already
calculated, so we
don't need to recalculate it.
So it just takes
the value right away
and then the output
downloaders is done.
And then this happens again
for the next two or three tabs.
Oops, I was hovering, sorry.
And then the detail size,
detail account, detail unique.
The whales by hour, detail view.
It was a very big plot.
It took a little bit
of time to show up.
But we had the--
Given Full Puppy, this is the
traffic that they were doing.
Very funny.
And not very many--
1,800 unique packages, but
downloading them constantly.
So someone had a while
true download file.
So we're going to
go through here.
So that's how the
plot information
will show up for that
one piece of information.
And if you noticed,
there is actually
a blue state, a frozen
state, and that's
what happened with one of the
input values that we froze.
So let's zoom back, see
if we can find it quick.
Hold on, there it is.
Frozen.
This input details was
frozen because we're
trying to avoid a
situation where,
if you open up a new view
but you haven't had all
of your selected values
actually selected, then
you may want to freeze the input
value so that your plot doesn't
error out.
You can do this with maybe
like a req() false instead.
That would cause it to update
once the input value does.
But you still may need the
special case of frozen.
If you have this funny
situation with plots
and you see it just
for a quick second,
maybe check out something
about freeze reactive values.
And you can see more information
in the [? docs ?] there.
It's a rare situation
but it does happen.
And then last, I want to show
that ability to do the subsets.
So we were looking at
All Hour to begin with,
that was that home screen.
So we can double
click on All Hour
and all of the right
and left keyboards--
You know, so I'm
actually going to jump
many, many steps in the
reactlog because nothing
occurred on this subset.
But if I back up just
a little bit then,
hey, everything starts
updating quickly.
Just to see these
here, white values
are reactive values that
will exist eventually
but do not currently exist.
So input count has not been
touched up to this time point.
And now it finally
has at this time.
That's why I like to show
it when it's first idle
because everything's stable
just for a little bit.
One thing to look
for with reactlog,
because you'll find some
shocking behaviors every once
in a while--
and this is what Joe referred
to as, in one of his talks,
as an anti-pattern --and
basically what happens
is if you observe on something,
like an input button,
and you use a render
method inside an observer,
this is typically bad.
There are use cases.
Like you add a new tab where
it has completely independent
reactivity.
Cool, you should do this.
But in this case, if
I just want to render
a plot to bad pattern,
something that's a static name,
and this expression
will actually
be evaluated many
times, that is actually
making new render plots over
and over and over again.
And that is bad.
Instead, what we should
do, is calculate some data
such as a click count.
And call render plot
and wait until the input
button has been clicked.
So I require the input
button to be not zero,
and then I'll give
you the input button.
That was the goal of this thing.
Such as when the button is
clicked, render the plot.
So instead we can
say, make a reactive
on input button that says you
require it to be something
truthy, or non-zero.
You'll have click
count, and then we
render the plot given
the click count.
If you really wanted to
be dynamic and random
you could do it using
a dynamic output ID.
That's OK.
That's kind of like
inserting a new tab
or doing something
that has completely
independent reactive logic.
But the typical use case
of click the button,
render the plot, this is bad.
And we'll see it in
reactlog log plain as day.
So let's click the button.
OK, click the button.
OK we got some new plots.
Let's actually take a
look at this reactlog.
And you can see that
the reactlog will get
taller, and taller, and taller.
And this is because we will have
more and more outputs of output
dollar bad pattern.
So let's move forward
in the reactlog.
So we can see that this
output bad pattern will
be calculated at some point.
And then it's finally
calculated there, great.
You don't really notice
it off of one click.
But what if we clicked it one,
two, three, four, five times.
And now let's refresh.
Let's mark this time point.
Marked, great.
And let's refresh
our application.
Now our reactlog
is a lot taller.
And if we zoom in, we can
see output bad pattern,
output bad pattern,
output bad pattern.
There's four of
these, five of these.
And so I can search for that.
And they're all making
different plot objects,
and they're all listening
to the same inputs.
So this is not good.
And none of the output bad
patterns exist at any one time.
Like they're not
coexisting at any one time.
And so this is an
anti-pattern and something
to avoid if you see it.
It's not the worst but
it will cause issues
after hours, and
hours, and hours.
[DING]